[Applaudissements]
si la grave
[Musique]
voilà on est des gosses c'est sûr mais
c'est vrai donc on dit ta gueule kaunas
des trucs comme ça mais c'est le coach
enfants et vous vous êtes un gamin on
vous adore parce que vous êtes un gosse
et puis les autres qui vous détestent
pour les mêmes raisons 500 vous êtes
vraiment à acheter un haut potentiel
vraiment émotionnelles parce que je
trouve que vous êtes à la fois perché
lunaire sincère vous êtes une bouffée
d'air frais dans cette dans cette
édition est pour moi vraiment vous êtes
un ovni dans la galaxie kolontar après
on n'a pas vu est là mais on n'avait
jamais vu un candidat comme ça voici un
petit job et maniéré vous avez pu être
complexé l'an justement ce ses manières
et je trouve que justement vous êtes
tellement touchant moi je vous dis les
ados en a j'en ai trois ils vous adore
et que voilà c'est vachement bien
tellement c'est aussi la belle top 50
goal castaldi vous adore mais il a mille
deux cents enfants vous aux littoraux
santos penser que c'est normal le
landais s'inquiétait à cette fête je
sais pas je peux pas vous savez pas vous
vous avez enquêter là dessus oui on voit
bien sa main on la voit en bol accord il
ya une bagarre et ouais et quand on le
voit chez eux en tout cas c'est vrai
c'est avec toi ça mc voix sur d'autres
photos
ouais il à la mc carey oman doit le
rester vraiment c'est vrai c'est vrai
c'est vrai c'est quand même aberrant et
puis moi j'ai faim je fais un appel à
témoins même encore aujourd'hui le
monsieur qui est là et si c'est pas le
landais mais qui téléphone qu'il
n'espérait que dit monsieur ou alors
quelqu'un qui le connaît ce monsieur
s'est produit mais non c'est pas lui
vous l'avez déjà fait ça et personne n'a
personne n'a appelé pour une bonne
raison c'est que le mec est là il est en
taule en jouant pour vous c'est normal
le long des séries
on est là pour donner là pour écouter on
peut en costume et du coup ça commence
quand j'étais nous offrait ce que l'on
peut encore changer
dominique global blue qui tous la balle
aux mises sur son portable on va voir
ici oui bonsoir monsieur le ministre
oui bonsoir c'est monsieur hanouna cyril
on est en direct sur touche pas à mon
poste
j'espère que me regarde à défaut d'être
ici ah bah merci oui et sympa oui alors
on a le ministre au téléphone
est ce que est ce que ça peut bouger
monsieur le ministre est ce que ça peut
bouger non de travail et une réponse
demain cette semaine c'est encore des
aménagements j'en avais déjà d'accord et
à l'histoire du hors contrat aussi
[Musique]
d'autres sujets
l'année dernière vous l'avez fait pour
les mets toi tu l'as d'or tu as des
tamoutoi canal+ on va manger on va
manger des des tacos 3 bien sûr c'est
pas le palais des biens s'est passé je
vous salue les bruits sont pas d'ordre
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
la presse
elle convient d'un rendez vous entre
vous il y avait je suis dur est suggéré
de regarder un film comme vous dites
dans nous a chambre la jeune femme est
également évoqué le fait qu'il y ait eu
consommation de drogues à votre domicile
il m'a proposé de la la maline à nokia
c'est vers minuit nous en avons pris
vous savez ce que c'est de la madine
j'ai pas du tout c'est quoi c'est un que
de l'iprem met d'accord moi je ne
connais pas du tout un cachet de la
manne insee qui vend de 2co doliprane
mais comment est ce qu'on se marre ça
cogne un peu que j'en ai pris quand j'ai
eu le centre potosi
moi j'en ai c'est un vrai médicament ce
n'est pas innocent moi j'en ai parce que
je me suis coupé le doigt et on a créé
ce cri d'en prendre 10 par jour
c'est alors que douleur on en a pris
mais pourquoi pour qu'on a appris un
ennemi ensemble parce que d'élire en
fait ça fait parce qu'on est des enfants
en fait et parce que on avait parlé tout
l'après-midi soit au jardin du
luxembourg etc on ait parlé de ce qu'on
a déjà pris des drogues est ce qu'on
avait est-ce qu'on buvait tous les dons
étaient un peu il ne soit en mode
balanant pas trop là dit elle même vous
ne pouvez pas ressentir d'effets quand
vous prenez un cachet de co2 ni prime
vous demandez je voulais vous demandez
peut-être parce qu'ici on prend des
rails de coke sans difficulté moi j'en
ai jamais eu
c'est très bien c'est bien mais ça reçu
en place ou non mais attendez il ya un
moment il faut arrêter un coup vous êtes
en train de jouer avec moi de chanter
vous qui vous n'êtes pas quoi de qui on
parle et vous allez encore du milieu de
la télévision du maire de la division
mais tu parle de moi mais pourquoi vous
semblez pourquoi tu parles comme ça à
dos rail de coke l'épreuve la santé vise
et jamais personne n'a pris de la
colombe personne de prendre des drogues
dures dois je dire pourquoi est-ce que
je t'adore nom m'est arrivé d'y des
propos est-ce que je vais pas trop parce
que je parle de presse que je parle de
ce faire tout ce qu'il veut dans mais là
c'est pas bien mais cela pourquoi est-ce
que je parle de ça c'est pas bien je
parle de ça parce que c'est ce qu'on
essaye vous veniez à ces injections le
banc des accusés et vous seriez vous et
les autres je suis sur le banc des
accusés ah oui vous êtes sur le banc des
accusés l'alcool place jusqu en 2010
votre vie va être agressée sexuellement
par son entraîneur de boxe il devait la
ramener après son entraînement
mais il arrivera avec trois heures de
retard tafer avez un compte facebook et
je suis rentré à l'intérieur de son
compte facebook et en direct j'ai lu où
elle marquait ne reste jamais seul avec
l'entraîneur à son autre petit camarade
de boxe n'aurait jamais seul avec
l'entraîneur j'ai eu trop trop peur et
l'autre petit tu dis qu'est ce qui s'est
passé et ma fille lui dit je peux pas te
dire j'ai eu trop peur mais ne reste
jamais seul est la halle aux gamines lui
dit il tu as fait le coup de la
camionnette et ma fille lui dit comment
tu le sais et lui dit bah moi ça fait
déjà plus d'un an que ça dure
il ya un très gros réseau derrière moi
je sais moi je parle veux pas parler de
réseau je préfère parler crime organisé
aujourd'hui on en 2021 on peut pas dire
que la mafia ça n'existe pas donc je
peux vous dire que dans ce fameux club
de boxe de challes-les-eaux il ya des
noms du grand banditisme qui sont cités
et grand banditisme en existe vous avez
quand ça sortira moi j'ai eu beaucoup
beaucoup de témoignages un climat de
menaces quand même à voir - non non non
dans cette affaire oui oui j'ai parlé
avec des gens qui craignent pour leur
lait
jour relativement qu'elles sont
introduits note rhodia le doigt dedans -
tome 1 qui était vrai il décide les
batteries parce que c'était vraiment
bizarre
j'étais toujours en état de choc il
s'était inquiété trajan pouvais plus
depuis le départ je faisais tout pour
que ça se passe bien je devrais je te
tabasse je n'en pouvais plus je crie la
personne qui intervenait à ce moment là
au sol et un policier qui sort son
téléphone et une photographie il prend
en photo avec son téléphone alors que
j'étais nul j'ai beaucoup de respect
évidemment pour l'appeler mais vous dit
à monsieur que certains délinquants
parce qu'il a un casier judiciaire comme
monsieur éclair à l'époque et je me
souviens que zemmour avait dit en gros
il a un casier donc en gros bon ben
voilà c'est bien fait pour lui on ne
peut pas dire ça monsieur
même si monsieur un casier judiciaire
long comme le bras il n'a pas le droit
d'être agressés savoir maintenant si
vous allez commencer vous admettez avait
commencé par monsieur vous avez un
casier judiciaire parce que j'aurai
savoir la personnalité ce qu'un individu
parce que vous quand vous confiez votre
savoir qu'il se réalise et une agression
mais géraldine armées géorgiennes à
raison là dessus mais juste un véhicule
volé d'élite fait du mal à expliquer moi
en 30 secondes
la stratégie de ce garçon pourquoi il
fait ça vous pouvez expliquer alors je
vous pose une autre question
expliquez-moi la stratégie de mes
collègues qui vont être dans une fouille
on va retirer leurs gants et qui vont
lui mettre un doigt dans le cul et c'est
que ce put your un chardon ça existe et
vous les voyez aussi madame mais les
deux côtés c'est bon alors ça vous avez
pas d'arguments j'en ai pas donc c'est
50 50
des 91 20 ans vous vous êtes pas vu les
deux ça fait pas vingt ans puisque on
s'est croisé de temps en temps dans des
soirées mais ouais mais vraiment quelque
chose bien sûr que ça me fait quelque
chose parce qu'on a vécu une histoire
ensemble ouais pas qu'une histoire on a
vécu un événement enfin le changement de
notre vie on l'a vécu tous les deux
ouais merci tu vises un tu veux boire ou
loana ou pas ça fait quelque chose non
mais j'ai déjà extrêmement heureux
qu'elle soit là parmi nous mois loana je
suis un peu ému parce que j'aime
beaucoup je lui ai tendu la main
plusieurs foires j'ai pas compris mais
j'ai appelé il voit tout je sais pas si
tu l'as dit mais c'est une partie de mon
histoire aussi donc quand tu es pas bien
envie d'embêter les gens je sèche un peu
comme toi mais parfois il fait ici
l'idée à plusieurs reprises à trois fois
jurait encore trois fois j'ai tendu la
main jeudi à venir au mans jeta que chez
moi je ne voulais pas qu'il ait enquêté
sur un truc vous avait infiltré en
partie d'accord je veux bien l'admettre
ça mais quand on infiltre en partie on y
reste quand même coup plusieurs mois on
attend d'être élu pour avoir une vision
globale
là vous êtes infiltrez vous êtes barré
au bout de trois jours mais vous êtes
très quoi mais ma mémoire m un mur qui
est infiltrée au bout de trois jours il
a ça mais je me mets cerveau j'ai pas
honte de dire que la pression
effectivement le faire reculer bien sûr
voilà donc c'est uniquement sur arm est
inventée par les histoires parce que
c'est malhonnête dans tous les cas la
tendance et en blesser au comblement
salah kamel sanhadji alors non j'ai une
dernière chose promise 15 secondes
km je me fais appeler km avec mondial
alors sur mclaren entier c'est kamel
boudjellaba penh cambodia là parce que
quand je vais dans un moteur de
recherche très connu et je tapais kamel
morjane a envoyé tout ce que j'ai fait
en termes de militants mais associations
les débats que j'ai mené que des
politiciens tout ce que j'ai pu mener
mais heureusement la star n'aurait pas
accepté en fait qu'ils aient déjà
bédéphiles traitement si vous êtes quoi
ou six mois à l'elysée s'il vous plaît
vous êtes gens d'amis facebook j'ai dû
le supprimer parce qu'on voit manifester
et sera donc pas partir jimmy comme et
la gadoue déjà là quand on tapait dans
le moteur de recherche y avait plus rien
kane sur quoi les candidats humains ont
été calquées sur l'élevage imlach était
tellement nom était il faut soyons
concrets pour changer lecture quand je
vais changer
georges on les a
les abattoirs il faut les changer vidéo
dans les abattoirs compris à ce qui s'y
passe bien on a dix secondes alors la
dce convention universelle
le système de la domination masculine
qui s'approprie pour produire des
millions d'individus et les transformer
en viande
voilà merci merci d'être massacrés
montants seront détruits le seul bon bah
je suis très